welcome back republicans are slamming
nancy pelosi for having misguided
priorities with one congressman slamming
her for
bringing members back to vote on
marijuana and
tiger king legislation instead of ppp
funding
and cover 19 relief the congressman who
tweeted that is arkansas republican
bruce westerman and he joins us live now
so
this is a pretty interesting turn of
events you have votes taking place
on cannabis and big cats but covid 19
relief is still being negotiated what
are your thoughts
well good morning carly good morning
julian great to be with you and
you know i was thinking it's the lame
duck we've got a few weeks of
legislative business left
and i was shocked to find out we were
coming back at least part of us were
coming back republicans were coming back
to d.c
to vote on marijuana and and tiger king
you know with with covid peaking with
small businesses closing you know jamie
herrera butler
proposed that we do a discharge petition
to spend some ppp
funds to help these small businesses
that are struggling back in september
and
the speaker has ignored that and i i
you can't make it up i can't believe
we're here back in d.c
with just a few weeks of time left
and the government's not funded the
military is not funded
but by golly we're going to vote on pot
and tiger king well i guess some people
you know make the argument that both
sides are blaming each other right now
for not getting
anything accomplished as far as stimulus
goes um with covet 19 relief go
let's go ahead and take a look at this
this is a nancy pelosi and chuck schumer
statement after backing the bipartisan
908 billion dollar stimulus bill this
was yesterday and this says quote
many family budgets and small businesses
are at their breaking point
in light of the urgency of meeting the
needs of the american people and the
hope that the vaccine presents
it's time for leader mcconnell to sit
down with democrats to finally begin a
true
bipartisan effort to meet the needs of
the country so now at this point after
backing this they're kind of punting it
off to mcconnell
yeah that's unfortunate because we've
got funding remaining in the cares act
that we just need some tweaks to get
this funding out
to businesses and to give governors
flexibility on how they spend the funds
it's really unfortunate the way people
are hurting across this country
and we can't just make a few tweaks to
get this needed funding out there and i
think it
it speaks volumes to what we're seeing
across the country you know
uh joe biden said something about
and i'm glad he admitted this that
democrats have forgotten rural america
but i think it goes
deeper than that we're seeing a divide
that i believe
peggy noonan captured this best back in
2016 when she wrote about
the protected and the unprotected and
then brett stevens with the new york
times followed up just this past may and
he talked about the remote and the
exposed
i represent a large rural district and
my constituents don't have the
opportunity to not go to work
their jobs require them to go to work
they are exposed they can't work from
their basements
and when we come back to vote on pot and
marijuana
and a lot of democrats are sitting at
home in the safety of their basement
collecting paychecks
uh and basically thumbing their nose at
the people that are
working to make sure that there's food
in the on the grocery store that is
delivered
that's just hard to take yeah you know
just real quick um just to
because you referenced it uh biden did
make comments on rural americans
recently he said you know it really
goes to the issue of dignity how you
treat people i think they just feel
forgotten
i think we forgot them so interesting
comment from uh
joe biden that i have a feeling you
agree with congressman westerman thank
you so much we appreciate it
thank you have a great day